the difference between games and other
forms of media is a pretty interesting
one and while games can obviously be
unique and different in all sorts of
ways it's fascinating to see what can
happen when they take inspiration from
another medium so that said let's talk
about games that take inspiration from
cinema we have games that feel like TV
shows such as tell tales episodic
masterpieces and games were just
straight-up adaptations of films or
books this group of games though is
something different some of them are
working to incorporate the cinematic
look into their games by using an
intentional art direction to get a game
to look like it was shot on film for the
big screen take the order 1886 for
example developer ready at dawn said
that achieving this kind of constant
cinematic escapism is what they thought
to find a next-gen game rather than
high-definition graphics at 60 frames
per second the cinematic look of games
may be easier to achieve given the
current state of Technology but we've
also seen a bunch of games take on a
cinematic style in the way that they
tell stories take Metal Gear Solid for
example this series has always been
infamous for its many lengthy cutscenes
Metal Gear has one continuous epic story
to tell and much like watching all the
harry potter movies in the space of a
week playing through the series feels
like you're along for one big convoluted
ride although Metal Gear creator Hideo
Kojima expressed his interest to make
the cut things more interactive as the
series progressed and wants to minimize
cutscenes in the next installment the
phantom pain there's no denying that the
middle gear series wears its cinematic
inspiration on its sleeve James Bond
films and escape from New York are the
most obvious in an endless list Metal
Gear Solid takes their epic secret
espionage action mission tropes as
gospel and recreates them with polygons
and spreads the characters a big boss
and solid snake were basically directly
lifted from Sean Connery and Kurt
Russell and what better way to perfectly
capture all those juicy double crossings
conspiracy theory
and dastardly plans to take over the
world as well as those classic films
lots of cutscenes of course Metal Gear
Solid actually holds a Guinness world
record for the longest cutscene sequence
in gaming sitting at 71 minutes although
when you're capping off a story that
spans over 10 games that's not too bad
if you were to take a metal gear solid
game and get rid of all the awesome
gameplay sections the pacing delivery
and narrative structure would still let
you have a pretty good time in fact
Konami did just that a cutscene only
version of Metal Gear Solid 3 was
included as a bonus feature for the game
subsistence free release you see a
similar sort of cinematic implementation
with games like Uncharted and heavy rain
I'm childhood is let's face it basically
Indiana Jones with a slightly hotter
protagonist as for heavy rain although
it features a branching narrative it's
carefully crafted cinematography and
method of storytelling which paste
itself similar to film while still being
flexible is prevalent throughout the
game and finally cinema has invaded
gaming not simply in how it looks or how
the story is being told but also who is
being cast in the title roles and how
performance is captured David cage is
taken a shine to casting big-name actors
in original roles within his games most
recently casting Ellen Page and Willem
Dafoe in beyond 2 souls Quantic Dream's
latest quick timing creation the
massively cinematic le noir prominently
starred aaron staton from madman and
freaking Kevin Spacey was in Call of
Duty advanced warfare for God's sake
these games and many others like them
move beyond voice work and also utilize
motion and facial capture technologies
to try and accurately represent the
likeness of the actors in order to fully
embody the characters you may not have
recognized all the voice actors who
worked on the last of us well apart from
Troy Baker and not Ellen Page but the
well written dialogue and spot-on
performances were deemed to be so
engaging they performed it live on stage
let me know if you reckon games can
learn anything from movies or if you
even like games that go for that
cinematic feel leave me your comments
and I will catch you next week